[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: So Kevin Kelly, the
co-founder of Wired Magazine,
has this wonderful idea about
how the emergence of language
was actually the first
singularity, right?
In other words, the world on
the other side of that line,
after language
emerged, would have
been unimaginable
to the creatures
standing on the previous, on the
other side of that line, right?
Trying to explain the nuances
of a Shakespearean sonnet,
to an ape, are
simply unimaginable.
Right?
This is inconceivable, we simply
lacked the wetware, right?
So language.
What is language?
Kevin Kelly says
it's a tool that
allows the mind to know
what it's thinking, right?
It turned a feral
mind into a tool
that could now think with
purpose and deliberation,
right?
Language allowed us to create
a virtual world in our heads,
and pull the present
forward to meet that.
The ability to design, to
envision, to plan, to imagineer
was the natural consequence
to the emergence of language.
Again, a tool that
allows the mind
to know what it's
thinking, right?
Language has to
do with sentience,
before language, there
was no self-awareness,
there was no self
consciousness, right?
Language came about as a kind
of vortex of self-mirroring.
Right?
Language and
self-awareness is kind of
like plugging a video
camera into the TV,
aiming it at the TV, and then
seeing the engulfing infinity,
right?
The recursive infinity
loop that gets
formed, and-- and,
I don't know, I
find that idea to
be astonishing.
And when you really think
of how it transformed
the mental operating
system, right, you
can see why Kelly would call
it the first singularity.
Language.
[MUSIC PLAYING]